For the functions we've used,
we haven't needed to know about the code inside the functions.
For Math.random and Math.max,
we aren't exactly sure how Java calculates a random value,
or it chooses a max out of two numbers.
We've treated these functions as black boxes,
and only needed to know what the functions do,
what parameters they have,
and what data they return.
We only needed to read the documentation to be able to use these functions.
These documents are a summary of what a function does,
and it's a good idea to include them in your own code.
Especially, if you want to share your code with other programmers.
Or even if you're writing a lot of code and
making a note to yourself about what a function does.
So, let's see how to create your own Java documentation.